et
avec nous pour en parler france 4 9
délégué départemental du modem dans le
nord bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau philippe gurria qui
conseiller régional écologiste en
ile-de-france bonsoir félibre bien
qu'ils merci d'être avec nous alors une
réaction pour d'abord à ce témoignage en
convient d'entendre cet avocat qui a
game 20 ans de droit derrière lui
considère que le pass vaccinale est une
atteinte aux libertés individuelles
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup un avocat
qui partagent cette pensée france 4
boeuf emmanuel macron à rogner dans la
liberté des premiers pardon la liberté
des français vous comprenez un certain
agacement est en tout cas dont on peut
sur le plan juridique et pas
nécessairement politique
bonsoir à vous tout à coup vous m'avez
donné un petit coup de vieux permettez
moi de vous le dire puisque j'ai trente
trois ans d'enseignement en faculté de
droit et je me sens donc un sage et le
ça je peux vous dire que bien sûr et
j'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois votre
antenne les mesures qui sont prises
réduisent nos libertés bien évidemment
mais pour autant je pense que nous en
sommes tous d'accord elles ont été
prises c'est vrai avec une sorte de
précipitation mais la situation le
justifiait
lorsque le bâtonnier andré dit que
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
suffisamment discuté mais écouter
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation
d'urgence
on ne peut pas non plus discuter pendant
des semaines ou des mois et laisser
passer les décès avant de se demander
comment soigner les morts
alors oui il y a eu des mesures qui ont
restreint aux libertés
oui elle était indispensable
et oui je pense et françois bayrou l'a
dit lorsqu'il y aura moins
d'hospitalisations
il faudra sérieusement penser
effectivement
évidemment et c'est bien naturel a
recouvré la liberté le conseil consiste
constitutionnel a visé un équilibre
qu'on appelle le bilan coût avantage il
y avait plus davantage que de coûts à
restreindre provisoirement nos libertés
et il y aura bien sûr une nécessité
urgente de les recouvrer dès que la
situation sera apaisée à saigner ou un
peu normalisée philippe vauriac tir vous
êtes aussi cléments que france 4 bof
on a rogné nos libertés écoutez je j'ai
noté une phrase assez drôle soigner les
morts quand ils sont morts on a tous
besoin de l'espagne est bien évidemment
et je pense tu veux dire prévenir plutôt
que de soigner nommant
il ya quelque chose qui est très simple
monsieur le délégué et moi même je pense
que tous les deux nous sommes pas
médecins il y à une organisation une
petite organisation environ nous
s'appelle l' oms organisation mondiale
de la santé et puis on a un petit truc
qui s'appelle le le comité scientifique
que vos
vos responsables parce que là du coup je
me retrouve en marge et je me retrouve
plus et non par en marche
ne consulte pas l' oms ainsi que le
comité scientifique ne recommande pas la
vaccination obligatoire et se passe
vaccinale est une immense en langue
c'est le ministre de votre ministre de
la santé qui nous l'a dit c'est une
obligation b10 est de vacciner les gens
vaccinés oui nous sommes pour les
écologistes dès le départ d'ailleurs je
me rappelle que yannick jadot bien avant
que le vaccin soit disponible a été le
premier est décriée par tout le monde y
compris par vos rangs nous sommes pour
une vaccination
vaccination veut dire une protection
intégrale vous ne pouvez pas être
contaminé et vous ne pouvez pas
contaminer les autres actuellement nous
donne un booster pour remettre les
choses bien en place j'ai ma dose de
rappel parce que sinon c'est une mort
sociale comme a pu l'annoncer le
bâtonnier et j'ai aujourd'hui j'ai une
pensée sincère pour ces millions de
français demain qui vont se retrouver
sur le carreau et votre clémence votre
gentillesse par rapport à des gens qui
agissons urgence qui avait quand même
plus d'un an et neuf mois de recul pour
pouvoir intervenir donc lorsqu'on agit
en urgence comme ça ça s'appelle de
l'amateurisme et l'amateurisme
aujourd'hui être des millions de
français et de françaises sur le carreau
demain monsieur alors faut-il restaurer
nos libertés vous allez nous dire oui
c'est la question en tout cas que l'on
vous pose ce soir et une première
réaction d'agnès agnès qui nous dit
toutes ces restrictions n'ont aucun but
sanitaires bien sûr que nous devons
retrouver notre liberté par la force
s'il le faut fois en 80 comment vous
jugez ce genre de sortie parce que c'est
vrai qu'à nièce est pas la seule à il ya
plein de français qui estiment que ben
voilà le but il n'était pas vraiment
sanitaires il était davantage politique
vous dites c'est la théorie du complot
ou vous comprenez ce genre finalement de
sentiment qu'ont certains français
alors trois choses la première j'ai
vraiment qu'ils soient liés les morts je
voulais dire par-là qui on n'avait pas
réagi on aurait plus que des morts et
qu'on n'aurait pas pu les soigner
la deuxième oui l'organisation mondiale
de la santé a préconisé un certain
nombre de mesures et parmi lesquels je
rappelle qu'au début de la crise elle
disait que le masque n'était pas
indispensable et le gouvernant de ce
point de vue lui a fait confiance peut
être avec un léger excès d'optimisme la
troisième je comprends l'exaspération
je ne pense pas que ce soit du
complotisme je pense en revanche qu'il y
ait un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne font pas confiance au suffrage
universel et qui ne sont pas prêts à
accepter des décisions qui sont prises
par un pouvoir élu démocratiquement et
je constate d'ailleurs que ces personnes
ne font pas confiance non plus à
l'élection qui vient entre de madame
artaud à monsieur zemmour il ya quand
même un champ politique assez large
chacun peut trouver à s'exprimer dans
deux mois donc moi ce que je leur dise
et si vous n'êtes pas contents et
j'accepte tout à fait vous ne soyez pas
contents et bien voter voter pour des
adversaires du pouvoir actuel mais
envisager plus le vote que la réaction
violente et ainsi nous pourrons
continuer de vivre en paix tout de même
une petite question à parce qu'on va
passer aussi la parole à un sénateur qui
va nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
en direct aujourd'hui
certes la france fait partie des pays
qui prévoit des allégements les bars les
transports les stades les discothèques
mais paradoxalement dur s'il passe
vaccinale à la dose de rappel sera
réalisée au plus tard quatre mois après
la fin du schéma vaccinal initiale
jusqu'à sept mois jusqu'ici france 4 of
tout de même est ce que c'est justifié
alors qu'on sait tous voilà
malheureusement il ya encore des gens
qui sont hospitalisés on ne va pas dire
le contraire ici mais on sait tous de la
comique rond il ya un peu moins de
danger que le vaccin n'a pas
nécessairement été des plus efficaces
comme l'ont dit les scientifiques est-ce
que c'est toujours justifier le maintien
de ce pass vaccinale aujourd'hui
alors vous me posez la question à moi
qui ai reçu ma troisième dose à saint
malo cet après midi ça va nous arrêter
dans le fond mais oui mais je peux vous
confirmer que ça m'a embêté que je les
fais parce que j'allais perdre mon pass
vaccinale mais que je effet aussi parce
que je pense que malgré tout ce vaccin
réduit la gravité des cas et bien sûr
qu'il faudra supprimer le pass vaccinale
mais pour l'instant il reste encore de
très nombreux de nos concitoyens qui
sont hospitalisés et je pense que on
peut encore tenir à moi de moi avant de
recouvrer la liberté d'aller boire un
verre ça n'est quand même pas nous avons
conservé contrairement à ce que dit le
bâtonnier andré la liberté d'aller et
venir reste entière la liberté de culte
reste entière on nous a quand même pas
prise et de nous tous nos droits
fondamentaux même pas d'ailleurs de nos
droits face de l'autre mais heureusement
mais je suis d'accord avec vous mais il
nous reste deux mois avant de retourner
boire un verre écoutez ce sera tenable
quand ça sera les élections tient alors
ça content ça gronde aussi à du côté lr
vent sénateurs les républicains
appellent à lever le pass vaccinale sans
délai je propose de regarder voilà cette
infographie nous sommes vingt sénateurs
à l'air dont je fais partie qui ont
refusé de voter le peuple sanitaire
vaccinale pardon qui demande son arrêt
sans délai notre tribune collective et
paraît aujourd'hui dans le figaro
justement va être connectés dans
quelques instants avec elle a ouvert ses
dates heures et l'est de la côte d'or
l'un des auteurs de cette tribune
bonsoir alain houpert merci d'être avec
nous vous dites vous le pass vaccinale
se révèle être contreproductive ou
demander son arrêt immédiat
pourquoi ne pas suivre le calendrier
annoncé par le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent la levée du
pass vaccinale prévue pour fin mars
début avril s'il n'y a pas de nouvelle
vague ça fait trop loin pour vous
ça a été dit tout à l'heure le passo
knitter et c'est pas une mesure
sanitaire
lepage latina n'est pas une mesure
sanitaire c'est une mesure politique est
là la ficelle des très gros
saint-gabriel attal dit il
que la bonté du par la bonté du
gouvernement on va supprimer le pass
vaccinale quelques semaines avant les
élections
présidentielles déjà quand cette île de
l'état de l'épidémie on sait une chose
c'est qu'actuellement
l'épidémie on a parlé des morts a soigné
des morts il ya peu de morts et puis il
ya surtout des morceaux sio desmaures
sociaux
cambo j'ai appelé mon directeur de
la
sncf 30% des tgv sont déprogrammés
pourquoi parce que les gens ne veulent
plus aller dans le train parce que
beaucoup de gens ne veulent pas de cette
troisième dose et se passe vaccinale
elle faussement rassurant on l'a l'om
est ce le l'om est cela dit l'om est ce
qui est un organisme international
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
avec des grands spécialistes qui ont
quand même pris beaucoup d'autres q
parce que cette maladie maintenant on
l'a connu on n'est pas
on a gagné quelques années sur la
connaissance de sa maladie on la connaît
et on sait que ce vaccin ne protège pas
de de la contamination et ne protège pas
de la propagation et si on veut vraiment
impasse sanitaire il faudrait une tenue
un pass parts est
plus logique et se passe vaccinale il
donne il rassure faussement
les gens qui sont vaccinés qui sont dans
ce parcours vaccinale en se disant je
suis totalement
indemne de tout danger de vaccination je
indemne de 2,2 contre le danger a
redonné moi vous dit en gros le
gouvernement doit arrêter je cite je
vous cite d'emmerder les français avec
des mesures pour les ti sienne il faut
donc rêver se passe clairement
comme ils l'ont fait aux états unis
comme au royaume-uni pardon comme ils
l'ont fait comme ils l'ont fait au
danemark
souvenez-vous le royaume le royaume uni
c'est un des pays qui a été avec qui
serait de lens en israël ils sont en
train de reculer sur le quatrième dose
tout le monde est vacciné et
il ya une
en israël j'ai eu quelques coups de fil
de deux confrères israélien les hôpitaux
sont sous tension alors qu'en france les
les services de réanimation ne sont pas
ne sont pas surchargées et aider les
gens qui sont ré nomination ce sont des
gens qui ont des cornes comorbidités et
se passe vaccinale c'est un fourre tout
on veut tous vaccinés et c'est une
manière pour le gouvernement de dire
qu'il a raison le gouvernement a misé
sur le tout vaccin et c'est une erreur
une maladie il ya plusieurs façon de la
traiter le vaccin en fait partie et le
gouvernement a divisé les français en
mettant les gens qui sont contre le pass
vaccinale en les faisant passer pour des
anti vaccin ce qui est complètement faux
on est dans l'air oui de mémoire mais je
pars je pars je parle en tant que
parlementaire je parle en tant que
parlementaire ma connaissance médicale
m'a justement permis d'avoir des
contacts avec des chercheurs avec des
chercheurs qui ne sont pas des médecins
parce qu'un médecin c'est quoi c'est un
prescripteur c'est quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'on lui dit c'est ce qui fait ce qu'on
peut ce n'est pas un chercheur j'ai
contacté des chercheurs qui
qui ce sont les plus à même de nous de
nous renseigner et là on arrive à la fin
de ce débat et au vote a en tout cas
donné la parole on voulait vous vous la
donne et je vais quand même laissé
répondre également philippe bouriat qui
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
à nous avoir apporté
également votre opinion sénateur a l'air
de côte-d'or philippe briat qui vous est
sur la même ligne strict dallas où on
perd parce que ce discours peuron choqué
aussi certains ont du tout c'est un
discours réaliste je remercie monsieur
le sénateur de sa clairvoyance voyez
pourtant n'est pas de la même obédience
et on peut
lorsque les choses vont dans le bon sens
les saluer oui c'était un coup politique
c'est un excellent coup politique avec
le times incroyable orchestré avec une
main de deux mètres disant voilà deux
semaines avant le premier tour nous
allons lever le pass vaccinale les
masques etc enfin on a l'impression
d'être dans une série au lieu d'y aime
moi je voudrais dire une chose aux
délégués du modem conclure effectif qui
soutire énormément ce ce cette privation
de droits cette privation de liberté
personnes s'est offusqué chez vous
lorsque le président de la république a
refusé en russie de fait un test pcr
personnes pourtant c'est la base le
président poutine avait tout à fait
raison de demander à ce que le président
de la république fasse un test de pc
alors maintenant j'entends alors les
complotistes c'est plutôt les gens du
gouvernement non c'est pour éviter que
le président la république ou que les
russes puissent avoir l'adn du président
mais de qui vous moquez en disant ça les
services secrets français le groupe de
ses collègues présents de la public ne
peut pas récupérer les échantillons le
ts juste après de qui on se moque alors
on veut faire passer le président
poutine pour un grand despote mais ici
en france on a aussi le nôtre et je suis
pas sûr que le président poutine avait
tort en demandant une choses basiques
celle de faire un test pcr donc testons
les gens permettant que les tests soient
gratuits et là on aura une vraie
cartographie de ce qui se passe donc
assumer votre responsabilité assumée
votre désordre assumez votre lacunes
assumer d'avoir envoyé des blindés
devant des citoyens français
demandez à avoir la liberté et augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat on leur a envoyé des
blindés et je remercie votre rédaction
d'avoir été présent sur les
champs-elysées et partout en france pour
montrer la véracité et pas des chaînes
prom acronis qui ont essayé de nous
désinformer pendant tout ce temps la
france quoi toi par le mot de la fin
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce qu on
est déjà à la fin du débat depuis une
minute à les choses la première je pense
que le chef d'état étranger qui mettra
un coton dans le nez du président
cooking n'est pas né et de la même
manière un président de la république
n'a pas se permettre un retour dans le
nez lorsqu'ils visitent un pays étranger
c'est une question de dignité nationale
et se déplace avec son staff médical
nous attend nous dire que représente la
république n'a pas un staff médical qui
l'accompagnent 24,75 à rendre sur sa
santé environnement nous faisons des
santé c'est une question de protection
si vous avez pas signer pendant des mois
qu'il fallait se faire tester alertée la
protéger car et lorsque le président
poutine et des danses hongroises vont
enfin pays vous d'y glisser et de
réussir on se fait tester notre refusé
de le faire c'est vraiment scandaleux
vous nous obligez nous mais par contre
les oeuvres on vous demande d'appliquer
les lois vous refuser de les faire venez
d'être congédié de votre parti politique
en raison de votre violence verbale ne
tentez pas eu lieu bien phu cieux
n'était pas le test de monsieur
maquereau a lors de sa visite à moscou
mais voilà
voilà s'agissant des blindés ce sont des
blindés de la gendarmerie
personnes d'admirer quand même et je
rappelle que lorsque l'arc de triomphe
n'étaient pas protégés on a vu dans quel
état il a fini la moindre des choses
c'est d'assurer tranquillement et sans
agressivité
le respect des personnes et des biens
c'est ce qui se fait dans un état de
droit et ça n'a pas été du tout exagéré
d'ailleurs ya pas eu de violence
particulière et je me réjouis de parts
comme d'autres c'est dommage n'est pas
présent sur les champs-elysées vous
aurez les violences de quatre côtés
si messieurs en tout cas merci l'idée
était effectivement vous ne soyez pas
forcément d'accord c'est le jeu du débat
merci franck quatreboeufs merci à
philippe bouriat qui également alain
houpert qu'il nous a rejoints dans ce
débat merci